welcome to honest trailers commentary a
little late but always on time uh i'm
here with danielle alon and we are
talking about dune the other dune the
new dude new dude we're talking nadoon
uh we'll give you all our thoughts uh
about the film behind the scenes stuff
about the honest trailer we'll watch
some cut jokes uh which i believe we
have a few of this time um and we're
gonna tease you in next week's austria
and respond to comments and questions
from viewers like you i feel like there
should be bagpipes playing right now we
should be welcomed to the ringing sound
of futuristic bagpipes oh we'll get into
the bagpipes um but let's talk i think
my kid's crying that's that's kind of
bagpipe-ish um
so
we will uh uh we'll begin with broad
general thoughts about dune in that this
was a very uh hyped movie for me
personally i think i talked it up a lot
and said it was going to be the best
movie of all time and i think it was and
i was right you should never doubt me
again
any other thoughts questions feelings
danielle you're not a huge dude uh
doomhead are you
i liked it a lot better
the second time i watched it you don't
have to say that but no no no i did i
liked it a lot better the second time i
watched it because the first time i
watched it because again we we just did
the fir the lynch dune and so the first
time i watched it i like it it's just
like all of that zendaya like
on my planet
and so the first like 15 minutes i'm
sorry or just like
timothy chalamet uh bitching about stuff
i don't want to go to work i don't want
to work out i don't want to use the
voice i don't want to go to the desert
planet like
i think that they did uh they managed
the scope of it by really just zeroing
in on timmy c and i think that uh
lynch's dune like immediately throws you
into like the emperor's plan and all the
machinations and stuff like that but
they really are just focusing on um
little lil paul and like how out of his
depth he is and how he's just kind of
like a whiny little brat which is like
again like not
i can't imagine really enjoying it or
getting a lot out of it if you weren't
already primed for dune and knew what
was going on before you walked in but i
did so i loved it this approach does
make more sense like lynch i think loses
a lot of people right away in that first
scene where it's like what is this
little like guppy guy with you know the
guild navigator what we know as dune
fans like it's just so bizarre right off
the bat and i think it and it's so
esoteric and
dv doesn't even put that scene in this
film like we don't even ever see the
emperor we don't even know who's playing
the emperor yet we'll find out uh in
time for for dune two or two that's who
you're going
uh so yeah i think that was like the
right show like i'm not disagreeing with
what danielle is saying it does oh like
it does open with young paul in kind of
a whiny self-involved place but uh but i
do think that it makes more sense to
open with the characters and getting to
know house tradies
rather than jumping right into the huge
global universal questions of what's
going to happen with the spice melange
yeah and weird vagina mouthwarm
sure the sphincter vagina you know take
a pic
some kind of orifice yeah it's not clear
in the lynch movie if you read the book
it's like the guild navigators were
humans and then they just evolved
they're floating around in a in a
tincture of spice for so long that they
they don't need limbs anymore they're
not walking around so that that's what
happens it's like a faces yes diagram
you know everything you just said only
makes this movie more accessible for
people who haven't who don't know
anything about tim none of that we're
all waiting for tune on that one none
and you know there is a lot that i think
we're waiting on for part two um and by
the way just like faller of the year
moment is to before the sequel is even
greenlit is to put part one in your
title card
wow hey warner brothers like go ahead
ball's in your court um so bravo on that
but yeah you lose a lot um as you said
you don't even see the emperor you don't
get fade you don't get um a lot of stuff
and you lose a lot of context because
danielle i know you brought this up in
your notes but there's a lot of
i think critique or at least questioning
of like the white savior chosen one
narrative in the book and how that's
like weaponized against the people of
arrakis and stuff like that whereas i
think you can end in the lynch version
like it's kind of presented
unquestioningly or or maybe punted for
the sequel
because it's because all the people
they're
all the fremen and the lynch version are
white
yes that too yeah but i thought it was
such a cool concept from the book and i
don't know why they don't
think this is uh worth putting in there
is that like this is it's basically
colonialism it's like the catholic
people like not catholic not to single
them out but you know colonial powers
kind of paving the way to be like
somebody all these different planets
they plant these myths that someone is
going to come and arise and lead you to
greatness so that if they ever need to
it is mentioned in this movie
entirely in his version and it's purely
just no they had this prophecy and he's
there it came true yeah
and he makes it rain
he's the chosen one and now he's here
it's friday
and so i thought it was cool that they
already layered that in and obviously
that will pay off i think more in in
tune uh yeah there's gonna be there's
gonna be a lot of heavy lifting on on
timmy and uh zendaya's shoulders in this
in the second one so sure we'll see how
they handle that
and then dave batista too i think
they're mostly in this one to to wet our
appetites like
there's more payoff for those characters
as well as whoever gets cast is the
metal underwear clad replacement in this
dune boosh is what they are
doing
um all right well let's uh let's dive in
i know we have a lot more to say let's
watch the honest trailer for dune one
part one
of two
from the book of dude
after taking audiences deep into the
world of blade runners mexican drug
cartels and the spider-verse
so pause um
i'm told in the comments uh that that
was a clip from sicario 2 and i'm sorry
i don't know how that happened how would
we put a sicario 2 clip in there
i mean listen
it's the day of the soldier it's always
the day of the sold out over here
it's always the day of the soldado you
know we're sold out of us from way back
so yeah yeah maybe they just saw like
it's bro brolin's in both of them right
brolins in both of them yes yeah um it
was cool films uh well no parts well
it's surprisingly even after you're like
you know zakaria too not very good like
i'm gonna check it out it's surprisingly
not good yeah it turns out uh denis
villeneuve um and what taylor sheridan
wrote the ropes cardio right taylor
sheridan wrote both of them i believe oh
we wrote both of them oh yeah
although you know yellowstone folks
terrific yeah what a difference didn't
he makes
um are we gonna watch that uh are we
gonna watch that mayor of kingston i
watched the first two you want to go you
want to type kingstown just a brief
thumbs up thumbs down it is i i think
it's worth it's worth if you if you feel
like his vibe and that sort of world is
something you'd be interested in i think
it's pretty good it's a it's a better
role than jeremy renner's had in a while
yeah so what if you're a fan of jeremy
renner but only his music does he get to
show
well i mean he plays a singer song he's
a bigger songwriter the the mayor is no
there's no singing there's no singing in
songwriting it's a very hard edged crime
drama
all right let's keep watching dude
french canada's greatest hero since
whoever put gravy on cheese curds is
back with an adaptation of a novel that
seems really dense but at its core is
about getting high while your workaholic
parrots are distracted i'm sorry sir
won't happen again go
they said frank herbert's epic tale was
unfilmable and for a time it looked like
they were right or at least mostly right
i did not say this i am not here
but didn't even know that's the first
scene
proves that the secret to the perfect
adaptation was staring us in the face
all along just do half and worry about
the rest later hey we're great for
george rr martin he'll wrap up wins a
winner right after this blog post about
new york football
okay this one
this one
after this one okay okay one more
okay two more and that's just from this
season
all right pause um
well he did write uh elden ring which
i'm psyched to play that comes out uh
yeah well i guess that got delayed
february but um so he's doing he's doing
a lot of work on everything except when
he's got like eight tv shows in active
development he's doing fine he's got
plenty to fill his docket that's not
game
i mean who reads books no one's flying
right now no one's flying right now
remember that time you asked me and lawn
to name a book and we were like
listen
to me
eventually yeah
no weirdly like my uh my like movie
interest was so weirdly intertwined with
the novelizations of films like the
first books i loved were like michael
crichton books and i was like they made
movies out of these what that's true i
did go through a phase where i read a
lot of the crichtons that they were
making movies out of in grisham too i
got into doing that as well like if an
internet had existed like in the way it
does now it would have been posting
about like sphere is coming you guys
we're getting a spear
who's reading pelican brief before the
film comes out
i've read the novelization
[Music]
i was a christopher pike girl i got into
like all of his stuff when he started
doing adult novels where all like at the
end of the day all of christopher pike's
novels are i don't think i believe in
god but if i do he's [ __ ] up
okay all right wait
i'm confusing him with christopher
someone who did all the sports books
about like the boy who was the best at
sports
don't mind if i do matt christopher matt
christopher i've never read any likes
good good sports kid yeah oh man this is
taking me back tough to tackle i can't
relate to this
well i couldn't relate to playing sports
but i'm thinking about like a a boy who
never missed a free throw there should
be a ghost
who can't relate to football
uh anyways books are great uh as is and
dunes the books and dune is a dude i i
after i saw the lynch movie i read the
book dude and i i really liked it
dunes a book it's an all-time book
so many pages um
let's uh let's keep watching
it's 10 000 years in the future oh pause
sorry i'm sorry
this is other things we've got wrong um
already sicario too and then apparently
i know it says like it's the year ten
thousand whatever but that's actually
ten thousand years post
like some event it's not
bc or a.d it's not ten thousand years a
d it's like ten thousand years past
another thirty or forty thousand oh so
it's like 000. it's way longer like 40
000 years past our time um and which is
even more impressive that the bagpipes
are still around uh so sorry fact check
that that one honestly i i mean i
believe the fact checkers but i also
think that's stupid like i only have
beyonce well it doesn't make sense that
they'd still go post jesus like that
yeah like
it's okay but it's like oh no it's 30
000 years like come on shut up
my back checker is rhyme zone
it's it's too far it's just like your
mind is well you're like red and stimpy
like it's the year 400 billion like
yeah it's the future right all right
keep going in the future and the only
surviving piece of earth culture is the
bagpipes
this civilization runs on spice magic
sparkle dust that enables space travel
and makes bagpipes sound like way better
man the emperor has awarded house
atreides control over the desert planet
arrakis the universe's only source of
spice but he has a secret plan to betray
them along with baron harkinin what
darth vader's left
i know this is just like a straight shot
in there but i'd like to call something
out that we didn't in the in the trailer
because it's just like you know what's
cool is the the thopters i wish we
talked about how cool the thopters were
they were actually really cool and this
the sound design on them and just like
the way they flew and lifted off
we can't use a lot of music but i have
to say most of the music and dune slaps
like that soundtrack is really good
every time um the betty jesuret show up
like their soundtrack is like shut up
yeah zimmer zimmer really uh really gave
his all on this one and i i really like
i really like the technology and this
how it's like
sort of unsettling there's something
like almost like upsetting about some of
the way that the tech looks especially
how it's like it's always so huge and
it's kind of dwarfing the people and it
makes them look small and like they're
they're about to be crushed or forgotten
or another another thing that they're
doing if it still looks fragile and like
it could just fall apart at any minute
right yeah and it's like it's like oops
all bugs like everything looks like a
weird bug that can like
almost like a cronenbergian like there's
something that's just like viscerally
upsetting about it and i don't really i
really like that how it's like this you
know it's not like star wars i mean it's
like star wars in a lot of ways but not
in the way that like that's all about
like sleek cool looking
you know like dream fantasy technology
and this is like you know this really
like ugly post-post-industrial
you know yeah yeah star wars is like
having a good dream and this is like
having a bad dream about about being on
a the chosen boy on the desert um right
right
aaron harkin what darth vader's left nut
looks like under the armor but luckily
the atreides have some of the galaxy's
most brilliant tacticians skilled
warriors and they're well aware they're
entering a trap so there's plenty of
time for them to
still get their asses pounded into the
sand like anakin burnt watto's dinner so
pause this is this is just something
that they had to uh uh if not cut just
breeze past is like the machinations uh
of the arrakis at the iraqis the
atreides and the harkinans onarakis
before like during the handover and like
there's this great dinner party scene in
the book where there's all these dual
meanings and and a lot more
stuff going on in the shadows also like
the traitor within their own house that
kind of yeah i think that's the real
thing you miss is dr yui is like a
pretty key character in the book and
that the fact that it's him who would
raise the house is like a real
surprising moment and lynch does
matt like dean stockwell the great the
late great dean stockwell plays doctor
ewing lynch version uh and they they do
manage to kind of service that and
because that has a big emotional impact
on paul like this is one of the guys who
raised him who betrayed him and has led
to his exile and that that has a real
psychological effect in the book and
this just the movie it seems like they
land and then boom
yeah like barely even doctor hewitt is
barely even a character in this and i
did notice that that's a weird jump yeah
it goes a little fast from like all
right we're here oh we're all dead uh
better better get to hoofing it across
the desert um but there's a lot to do
you gotta get gotta get out there into
the desert folks yeah just get the kid
to the desert already uh all right keep
playing now the only hope for the future
of the house of hotties is sad boy paul
who picked the worst possible planet to
be an emo kid he's a lonely sullen teen
with psychic powers who would be a
perfect fit in the x-men universe
unfortunately on a ruckus professor x
just teaches you how to recycle your
piss beside them
uh i feel like
i just i either forgot about this or it
came too late but we really let timmy
see off
easy uh because didn't we it was just
like made uh a way we were just made
aware of him his dance career what was
his name oh yeah timmy tim
[Music]
yeah
tim and then also i spent a whole day
just going down that rabbit but i didn't
i thought the world was messing with me
for a little while i was like this is
just some random kid the other thing
that i guess we're also saving for part
two is that if we found out that he had
a youtube channel where he mods xbox
controllers that one i knew
one of us one of us
i love that i love that he's uh the
internet's boyfriend um used to be like
xbox elite mod controller 360 69 guy and
it was just uh just talking about the
cool the sick patterns he put on his uh
on his gamepad and now look at him movie
star uh every celebrity of his age oh
they're like yeah you're right they're
all gonna have
history there was all like what kind of
videos were you into when you were 14.
we know that you were into something you
were either on disney nickelodeon or
regretful youtube videos yeah yeah like
it's one or the other i think that
that's just generation yeah oh i can't
wait that's uh it's gonna be real fun um
all right keep playing to allow you to
drink the recycled water and how do
electric slide across the desert like a
bar mitzvah dj with heat exhaustion
follow me do the same moves
they did not need to adapt this part
with their house nearly destroyed
paulina so they already didn't have a
treacherous journey in search of the
fremont blue-eyed stand-ins for
oppressed civilizations who believe
everything and i do mean everything is
best settled via knife fight
[Music]
in fact most of the conversations in
this film pause for a second
um if i have one critique of lana's
you've nicknamed him dv i love that it's
much easier than saying oh yeah oh is
that not better yeah dv um is that i
think that uh
he doesn't seem quite as confident with
the with the hand-to-hand um action
scenes as he does with say a giant
levitating slab of concrete like he the
direction for the there was nothing
special
in all the knife fights that i saw uh it
seemed like kind of a standard action
scene and like i don't know
you kind of don't see a lot of scenes
like that in his films except for that
batista fight in uh in blade runner that
one's that's a great close quarters
fight but i was a little let down by uh
by all the the duels in this film um
just from a visual standpoint but just
by contrast because everything else
looks so spectacular um but hey maybe
that's just me just picking it's here
yeah i i think his his particular
abilities as a visual filmmaker it's
like the grandiose like big
huge scam set pieces and the the look
and the atmosphere and the aesthetics of
the movie but if you think about like a
lot of the pirates like like sicario
that
shootout at the border is awesome but
it's not it's not like close-up fight
choreography he's capturing it's like
this vast like you're getting the whole
sense of the whole border crossing and
where everything is and and that's also
shot by roger deakin so it's almost not
fair but uh yeah so i i feel like yeah
some of these fight sequences could have
probably benefited from someone who's a
little bit more experienced or skilled
with that kind of close quarters
actually which is a problem with a ton
of like western
action films like it's rare that you'll
see like a shanghai where it's like oh
the close-up fights of this actually
work really well like that's the
exception almost rather than the rule
for american
also i get like the reason why everyone
is wearing light suits because like
you're in the desert but that harkonnen
versus fremen fight i don't know who's
who
true yeah
yeah maybe they could all uh have like
more light up laser tag style armor that
would that would be really helpful
that's good
we'll save it for the special edition
um okay let's keep playing this film
take place at knifepoint with your
permission siren must check the
integrity of you
i have you hi you to join me in death
remove your hand from the box
they're a cross between the knight
that's also what the soundtrack sounds
like
like they make a mean paella
and the most enchanting member of their
tribe is andreas chaney watch her
briefly look over her shoulder for seven
total minutes of screen time but she
sticks around long enough to add another
notch to her cute little white boy belt
pucker up in wolford you're next
um yeah zendaya look she does she does
what's asked of her uh very well this
film but it's not much
and boy was she promoting the hell out
of this movie oh she was tap dancing her
ass off tap dancing is like the term for
when you go on like a bunch of different
like photo calls and you do all of the
promotion stuff she was testing her ass
off for this movie yes everyone everyone
was like oh cool zendaya and then we get
in there and it's like and thank god she
did because uh for however many um i
don't know zillennials or whatever she
tricked into seeing this is probably why
we have a part two i think without her
doing the big pro well this maybe
doesn't do she's got a real you know
like for a lot of these actors it's like
man part two whatever i'm dead already
but like for her
cartoons really her time to shine she's
got a real vested interest in getting a
part two because shawn is a much you
know a much bigger deal that's true
uh yeah the kids kind of take over well
because everybody else is dead um
kind of kind of killed off a lot of the
people at home
they're all they're all dead now yeah um
so yeah good for her but i think that
the ratio of like um junket interview to
screen time is probably as as high or
low however that works as as it's ever
been there were a few actors who were
really out there up front who are not in
this very much because batista too did a
bunch of interviews and stuff for this
and like he's he's blink and you'll miss
him but again he's got to be in the
sequel bar oh yeah
has a much bigger part next time yeah
they wanted to they wanted their uh
chance to shine and they'll get it for
dune part two and then if we get to like
three parts if we get to like part five
mamoa
oh yeah look out infinite mamoa
can't wait okay keep playing
they're joined by a massive ensemble of
beloved character actors speaking three
monotone lines of peace like it's an
audition tape for yale drama including
polka dot man as a human computer who
dies right away
thanos as a well-meaning aristocrat who
disappears right away aquaman who dies
but only after a while and poe dameron
as a space aristocrat who i don't know
why i
like mamoa better in this film than
pretty much anything else i've seen him
in i think cuz it's like he's taking it
down like a notch just a notch from like
his usual bro
broishness maybe it's like the beard or
the lack of it or something like that i
think this was like the i i like get
jason mamoan now more than i did in
anything outside of aquaman
well it's funny because like this is him
you're right because this is him taking
it down but it's also like he's still
the most natural person in the movie
yeah yeah
you're right that did um yeah he was
like
if it was a marvel movie he'd be like
the comedic relief who's always like
breaking the fourth wall and like
deflating the tension but he wasn't he
was just slightly
less uptight than everybody else
everybody else is delivering this very
like austere stentorian space opera kind
of dialogue and then he's playing it
more natural i do think it's also he and
paul like he and timothy chalamet have
genuine chemistry and those characters i
i think a lot of people enjoy their
relationship he's like the one guy who's
like paul's friend rather than mentor
and i think that that really comes
through and yeah it's just it's like
i don't think he needs to go like full
over the top
uh mamoa to to be effective i think that
he can be able to
preserve himself right i think sometimes
it's like aquaman he's he's at a ten and
we only really ever need him at a five
i'll say seven or so yeah all right keep
going
who dies right away because if you were
on the screen any longer the audience
would die from excessive horniness
but hey at least batista survives
doesn't do too much besides stand there
with his mouth open but he's alive gotta
give him that
so whether you catch it on the big
screen or hbo max or skip it entirely to
focus on twitter arguments about where
movies are supposed to be watched
prepare for a film with more stunning
visions of giants i mean should we
should we
do the discourse or no i don't care i
don't care i'm exhausted at this point
watch it watch it however you like i
really it has nothing to do with it it's
obviously better
on a big screen but who cares you can
watch it also i'd like to point out if
you're worried about like watching it at
home and people giving you a hard time
you could just lie
but just not talk about it because you
should just not mention it or you could
just be like watch dune on the big
screen in my state it was great i liked
it
but we won't know
uh that's well i will say the if we want
to address the critique that like if
it's not good on a small screen it's not
a good movie which i saw being thrown
around a lot yeah people saying
which i
do disagree with um because there's
multiple ways films can be good or bad
and the on-firing visuals is one aspect
of them and obviously that doesn't
translate the smaller the screen gets um
but that doesn't mean it's a bad movie
that just means that you didn't
get that aspect of it uh delivered the
way the way it should i don't know it's
it's it's
i don't care spectacle has merit i think
there's this idea that oh if a movie
isn't like deeply insightful about human
nature it's bad and it's like nah i mean
that's one way can be good that's great
when movies do that and if a movie's
trying to do that it should deliver but
like
being huge and amazing and and this
massive scale
that's a way that movies can be great as
well and it's it's perfectly worthy i
mean that's why movies are the the best
is because they can be so so many things
i mean it's visual arts it's audio it's
it's storytelling it's everything and
they can
shine or suck in every single dimension
possible so um yeah how are you going to
know uh how wasteful that water is for
date trees if you don't see it in imax
yeah exactly
[Laughter]
it's it's supposed to buggy right yeah
supposedly yeah
anyways uh
late arrakis capitalism right folks
also the spitting thing whatever
the spitting thing oh the spinning thing
this big thing makes sense i get it i
get it and then you'll share your
moisture everywhere yeah you know
it feels like the kind of beans no not
nope yeah you're right come on danielle
javier is going to go what's that waste
of bone juice
it feels
totally told them the spit thing and
they went for it like it feels like i
think
to outsiders to like mess with them
that's why a duke lido couldn't survive
is because he was a moisture threat to
all those feminists
we can't we can't afford it we can't
have him around he looks he looks like a
vogue cover like it was definitely like
oh i'm thirstier than usual oh no
well i'm glad that he's been the big the
big sexy takeaway rather than a tim
timothy shalom may have been it's
dessert planet am i right right
okay keep playing keep going
jeff bezos powerpoint drafts folder
that's definitely among the best films
of 2021 as long as you've already read
the book and can fill in all the missing
character development don't care that it
randomly ends halfway through the actual
story or oblivious to the fact that the
middle east actually has a number of
professional actors and have two and a
half hours to kill watching a contract
dispute between the exxon mobils of
tomorrow but hey if you don't watch it
now you'll be totally lost when they put
harry styles in the metal underwear for
part two
i think we did this on sju but who were
your your picks for fade in the sequel
for the sting roll
oh i think i said uh uh whoever hot
black duke is
oh yeah hpd i think i said yeah top
black duke from uh bridgerton sure oh
rajesh jean-paige that guy
if we're not going if we're not going
with stunt casting of like a musician or
oh no i think i said little nauseas i
said yeah oh wow that was too wide oh
that's
i don't know if i could top that one
yeah i was just gonna pick some you know
yeah it's like it's probably gonna be
like evan peters or something like that
i mean i think honestly i feel like
harry styles is a really solid pick and
we might have very well nailed it
because yeah just continuing the like um
musician that uh that is like uh yeah
seems like they can do tantra tantric
stuff yeah i mean if we do want to go
for a natural redhead i think rupert
grint could do amazing things in this
world yeah yeah
bring her back
put grit in the speedo get him out there
the quintessence yeah yeah um could i
suggest uh oh god i'm liking his name uh
ed sheehan yeah yeah
hmm because everybody loves it and he
pops his
fresh off his iconic cameo
i was gonna not say anything
i was going to
netflix informs me that it's such an
iconic moment cameo in red notice so i
can't wait good for him he's the
juggernaut congratulations i can't wait
to watch the first movie completely
written by algorithm as well oh you
haven't been very excited
all right we'll talk offline okay let's
do that uh all right keep playing
wonka vision
transmoms the spice must po
yomanda la shumulapaque
dunkin donuts
moving to the desert gonna find me a lot
of speeches dry dock and just the tip
yeah they probably won't hang forward
until dune 5 when paul's kid makes
himself into one and befriends the
reanimated corpse of jason momoa the
books get real weird strap in folks
oh yeah very spies
[Laughter]
i'm sorry but what the heck is this a
giant ant with human hands can't just
lay this on us and move on to knee i
don't care how much ground you have to
cover i demand context
i heard in the in the comments at least
that that was a huey's uh wife that
that's what they did to her
which makes it extra extra creepy
very troubling yeah
um awesome well uh i think we have some
deleted scenes and if so let us play
them
but at its core is about getting high
while your workaholic parrots are
distracted i'm sorry sir won't happen
again go and who can't relate to that
right i mean it's like gen x's catcher
in the rye
and the only surviving piece of earth
culture is the bagpipes
they make a huge comeback in the 5750s
this civilization runs on spice magic
sparkle dust that enables space travel
and makes bagpipes sound like way better
man pro tip just take one spice at first
and give it like 45 minutes before
trying anymore
starring
greetings tim the enchanter the shelton
one pro voice activist scenes from a
melange dune night swedish meatballs
floaty mcflute face
duty and the beast the dothraki
brobee one we're freeman from in tights
still guarant
sandy cause
tricky blue eyes hbo max von siddow
no dead land
house of sand and slog
siege and chinese spice dreams
i knew that was a stretch really you
guys folded space and moved the giant
bullhead thing between galaxies it seems
like it probably would have gone into
storage or even a caledon yard sale
suppose doesn't grow in trees you know
grows in worms
well it grows in uh worm larva just to
be uh oh boy in the year 41
328 specifically
just saying
that bullhead just bugged me i'm like
you guys did all of that work to pack up
and you brought the weird ominous
bullhead like just leave the blood at
home
it was a metaphor for their their long
uh lost matador ancestors or something
yeah
it's definitely like a visual motif that
he returns through throughout the movie
i couldn't necessarily tell you why but
he does there's a lot of like matador
and bull imagery with the atreides
throughout i mean is it as uh
stupid as like they're just the bull
that's like blindly charging and they
keep getting tricked and stabbed
probably something like this yeah uh all
right so we have a couple we have a lot
of fan questions but let's uh let's
start with these two uh from yoshimitsu
and by um aditya agarwal uh both asking
if any of us have seen the sci-fi
miniseries i have not have either i
haven't no i don't know for three sorry
a lot of people were saying
that it was like really good and i i i'd
always i felt like i'd always heard bad
things that's why i'd avoided it yeah
but
maybe you know opinions have changed and
i should check it out yeah yeah like
william hurts in it and james mcavoy
like something and i think that uh
if any uh
novel big dense sci-fi novel deserves a
mini-series it's it's this like um you
know if we couldn't have gotten this
this two film thing i would have uh
settled for like the six episode apple
tv plus um you know uh tax scam or
whatever they're doing on that streaming
service
this looks amazing it looks every
episode of foundation is like a booth
it's like right after c yeah 10 10 grand
per per viewer
besides james cameron's avatar and the
irishman which film has its experience
harmed the most when not on the big
screen hmm
i think um some for me uh having seen it
in imax 3d and then doing the honest
trailer for it on the laptop uh gravity
which i loved i loved on the big screen
in 3d was fantastic and like my heart
was pounding and then it looked real
silly
on the old laptop i'ma say tenant
okay i never saw a 10 in a theater i
watched it no no one did first um and i
i i think that that was one that would
have been way better if if theaters were
available i mean i think they were but
we were all like we don't have a vaccine
yet dude we're not going um i think
tennant probably could have benefited
more by
i will i will piggyback on that i still
like these films at home i don't i don't
mean why they're bad at home but nolan's
dark night movies especially the dark
knight in like imax on the big screen it
felt like a totally different experience
than then when you're home and you're
watching it on tv just when that
especially like in those the the big
action scenes when it fills the whole
frame it there's something really
immersive about what he's doing and i
know that we said not avatar but like
i'm sorry avatar in 3d in the theater is
a transformative uh it's like a
transformative experience like it really
is it feels like a ride like it like who
cares about the plot like you're very
you're like completely 100 360 immersed
a baby another another recent one that
occurs to me is doctor strange which was
really immersive and all like the
psychedelic kind of city folding effects
on the big screen uh which definitely i
think it's still good i still like it
but loses something
yeah
um all right susvera asks us to uh give
us your best voice use the voice
danielle
i'm just gonna do
i'm just gonna do my elizabeth holmes
first nation
use the voice line
yeah somebody killed me to give you
birthday just tell me i can't believe
[Laughter]
my spice
that's biased
um
okay i think that's really it we covered
pretty much everything else all these
other questions uh in our in our talk
anthony romeo asked better fan casting
for fade uh sci-fi mini series blah blah
blah blah uh we'll end on this a linger
sengor writes uh that he loves the movie
uh and book the trailer was amusingly
misleading about zendaya uh what other
trailers have misled you i'm still
shocked from bridge to terabithia what
was bridge to terabithia trailer oh
because it no it's just it looks like
it's going to be like a fantasy movie
and then it's like a very dark you know
like the grief
story about about death
that's why that's that's the bridge to
terabithia
i mean i remember uh um something
misleading in a
what ended up being a good way was that
the pan's labyrinth trailer made it seem
like a fantasy film like a like
like little rock
yeah they're playing that game i i i
will say uh executive decision really
yes i was going to be a steven segal
movie i loved that movie so much and uh
as a kid i was like what like that was
the craziest twist in any movie i had
ever seen up until that point spoilers
for a 20 year old movie but yeah he's he
skadoots after like 10 15 minutes do you
remember that that's interesting yeah oh
no i love that movie he gets sucked out
of a yeah he gets freaking airlocks
stealth bomber airlock and just like
plummets to his untimely demise and then
it's a kurt russell movie the rest of
that really [ __ ] kurt russell and
holly berry yeah really fun movie it's
still worth watching but just like that
that was like a genuinely shocking
moment the other one i was going to say
is toys you guys remember that robin
williams movie toys where they marketed
it like a robin williams comedy and then
it is a very like weird surreal kind of
dark like fable about violence and war
and like
not at all what i was sold on and i was
a pretty disappointed young person i'm
also remembering there was that i think
it was observant report which was like
seth rogen is like a paul it came out
the same time as paul blart and i think
they tried to make it into a goofy seth
rogen comedy and it was really just like
a sad dissection of like reactionary
masculinity like
oh what what's the morgan freeman
asteroid movie that also came out at the
same time
deep impact that was another one where
it's like i went to see that with my mom
i was working at the movie theater at
the time so we got him for free and my
mom was like well i'm glad i didn't pay
for that because i just wanted to see
like asteroid stuff and now i'm crying
yes
i just want asteroid stuff i just want
to try to
get to the asteroid
uh all right y'all uh this is really fun
um i love any excuse to talk to and so
i'm sure we'll find another one in the
future we we now get to hype ourselves
up for uh for tune um which starts
shooting uh early well the summer of
next year i love spending summer in the
desert
that's gonna be a hot it's gonna be a
hot one yeah it's a hot one yeah
like it's sand worms in the midday son
um all right we won't we won't put you
through any more singing uh but we will
be back next week foreign commentaries
with um
this is the uh
uh
this is a
story of a genesis uh but it's not sonic
but he still likes rings
that's right the phil collins story
everybody tune in next week so for the
phil collins story
thanks everybody for watching we'll see
you then bye
[Music]
you